lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
veamos dos palabras que están muy
relacionadas con las parábolas para
bolas
y esas son el foco de la parábola y el
foco de la parábola y la directriz de la
parábola direc
3 la directriz de la parábola bueno y
qué son estas cosas pues la parábola se
puede definir como el conjunto de todos
los puntos aunque bueno primero quiero
dibujar unos ejes cartesianos por aquí
tenemos aquí el eje de las sedes y por
aquí el eje de las equis gei eje de las
seis y eje de las equis y la parábola se
define como todos los puntos que están a
la misma distancia de un punto y de una
línea aunque el poco es el punto y la
directriz es la línea ya qué me refiero
con esto vamos a verlo con calma digamos
por ejemplo tenemos por aquí un poco y
un poco es simplemente un punto digamos
que este punto que es el punto
como ve que este punto es el punto y
coma ven así es que el punto a la vez es
el foco de la parábola y también
queremos dibujar la directriz pero como
ya usamos el color blanco para los ejes
coordinados ahora la directriz la vamos
a poner en morado y digamos que la
directriz es la recta que igual hace ley
de igualdad
esa es esta línea de aquí aunque también
se extiende en los reales negativos si
es que la directriz es la recta ye igual
hace ahora regresando a la parábola qué
significa eso de ser el conjunto de
todos los puntos que existen entre este
punto y esta recta aunque entre el foco
y la directriz pues por ejemplo este
punto de aquí está a la misma distancia
de este punto que de esta recta o que
está a la misma distancia del poco que
de la directriz
pero luego conforme nos vamos moviendo
del lugar con x mayor a los puntos que
están a la misma distancia del foco que
de la directriz son todos los puntos que
están en esta curva de aquí y lo mismo
sucede con las equis que son menores que
a ahora tal vez estés pensando que el
por qué por qué es que los puntos en
esta curva están a la misma distancia
del foco que de la directriz y para que
te quede más claro vamos a echarle un
ojo a las distancias entre estos puntos
y la recta y este otro punto a ver
empezando con este punto ve aquí
ok esta distancia entre estos dos puntos
tiene que ser igual a esta otra
distancia de aquí bueno entonces vamos
con otro punto si tomamos por ejemplo
este punto esta distancia entre estos
dos puntos tiene que ser igual a esta
distancia de aquí y si tomamos por
ejemplo este punto de aquí esta
distancia tiene que ser igual a esta
distancia y espero que entiendas muy
a qué me refiero con eso de que la
parábola es el conjunto de todos los
puntos que equidistante el foco y de la
directriz cree que estas distancias son
iguales así es que si tomamos este punto
de aquí este punto está en la parábola
porque la distancia de ese punto al foco
es igual a la distancia de este punto a
la directriz
y tal vez notes algo acerca de la forma
en la que tomamos las distancias de
estos puntos a la directriz y bueno lo
que sucede es que cuando tenemos un
punto y queremos sacar la distancia a
otro punto nada más medimos el segmento
de línea que une a esos dos puntos pero
cuando queremos ver la distancia entre
un punto y una recta lo que hacemos es
bajar la perpendicular a la recta que
nos interesa aunque hay buscar la línea
que pasa por el punto que es
perpendicular a esta línea directriz y
eso es lo que hicimos con todos estos
puntos
todos estos ángulos son ángulos rectos
estas líneas con las que medimos la
distancia de los puntos a la directriz
son líneas perpendiculares a la
directriz y listo
y todas las parábolas tienen un foco y
una directriz porque así se definen las
parábolas como el conjunto de puntos
x distan del foco de la parábola y de la
directriz de la parábola y bueno en los
próximos vídeos vamos a ver cómo se
relaciona el foco y la directriz de una
parábola a la ecuación de la parábola